him with i'm all up in the spot double
shot of henny g13 and blunts we got
plenty so get ready it's about to go
down shortly filling my style i'm about
to buy us around still high in the
clouds who's stepping in all that with a
con yeah cognac whatever
the mix i got a couple stacks to get i
hear the girls asking they wanna come
back to the crib girl you ain't gotta
ask how i live i can show you the world
light up your life you'll be in love
with your boy by the end of the night
cause we vip at the after party my name
ringing bell so they asking for me i'm a
superstar real dude real smooth this is
who we are putting work made moves i
don't came from nothing and tried so
hard hard work pays off we don't took it
this far jimmy
oh
i was born
my superstar
now you know my name my name
i'm nice with every word i spit just
throwing a beat and i'm a murderer i got
so many styles that i could hurt him
with i'm all up in the spot double shot
of henny g13 and blunts we got plenty so
get ready it's about to go down shorty
feeling my style